Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard guten
Morgen Markus wie geht's dir Johann mir
geht's ganz gut und wie geht's dir was
geht dir durch den Kopf
fragst du mich kann ich dir sagen weißt
du worüber ich gerade auf der Fahrt
hierher nachgedacht habe über eine
herrliche Pointe ich glaube sogar aus
deinem Mund und sie lautet alles scheiße
in deine Elli alles scheiße deine Elli
das war so so ein Spruch der späten 70er
ja früh in acht ja so meine
pubertätstzeit ja pass auf und jetzt
jetzt und jetzt habe ich einen Text für
dich Richard ja folgenden Text und sag
mir mal wie du den findest
Utopie und Resignation
menschheitsversprechen und
menschheitsversagen liegen heute wieder
so nah beieinander wie im späten
Mittelalter die einen erwarteten damals
das tausendjährige Reich Christi auf
Erden die anderen die große Auslöschung
durch den nächsten Krieg oder die Pest
aber gerade diese Gleichzeitigkeit war
wie wir heute Wissen der Anfang eines
neuen einer Wiedergeburt der
Menschlichkeit der Renaissance und wenn
wir uns heute selbst aus der Vogelschau
betrachten dann sehen wir die Menschheit
an einem eben solchen Wendepunkt wie
findest du das ja ich finde das klingt
sehr sehr weise wer hat das geschrieben
das ist eine Idee ja ich habe kein mich
ja erinnern wann und wo ich das
geschrieben habe
ich weiß das noch ziemlich genau
mein Leben mein Leben ist ja sozusagen
ein hoffentlich jahrhundertkampf ja
gegen den Pessimismus in mir und gegen
den vorteilismus und gegen das aufgeben
und so also jeder Tag ist ein neuer
Kampf gegen das Aufgeben wirklich naja
es ist ein bisschen so weil ich ja ich
habe das auch schon häufiger erzählt ja
es ist einer Familie kam wo zumindestens
mein Vater eigentlich einen gewissen
geschichtsverteilismus vertreten hat und
den vertritt mein Bruder auch und ich
war eigentlich immer damit beschäftigt
gute Laune ins Spiel zu bringen gegen
eine zu pessimistische Rücksicht und
deswegen habe ich eben auch dieses
Beispiel gebracht dass gerade in so
Zeiten wo man denkt jetzt geht
eigentlich alles den Bach runter und das
hat ja sehr viel Gemeinsamkeiten mit der
heutigen Situation wo man den
Klimawandel ist ja nicht mehr aufhaltbar
ja jetzt jetzt versackt und versagt die
Menschheit damit dass sie die
antinatalisten habe ich gelernt die
ganzen miesen Kriege des 20 Jahrhunderts
heute auch wieder im 21 Jahrhundert die
Geschichte hat Menschheit hat nichts
dazugelernt ne du kennst ja wenn dieses
Lieblingszitat Barbara touchman dieser
US-amerikanische Historikerin die
Michael gesagt hat die Menschheit hatte
irrsinnige Fortschritte auf so vielen
Gebieten gemacht ja also wenn man sich
mal guckt Geschichte der Medizin in der
Naturwissenschaften und so weiter das
einzige Gebiet auf dem sie nie
Fortschritte gemacht hat ist die Politik
so ich sehe das war nicht ganz ganz
genau so ja und das war damals
geschrieben unter dem Vorzeichen das
Vietnamkrieges während des Vietnamkrieg
seine Anklage ja also das mal wieder die
Barbarei zurückfällt und 20 Jahrhundert
und so weiter den Text können wir direkt
wieder neu auflegen könnte man direkt
der Untertitel des Buches das heißt über
die Unfähigkeit der herrschenden von
weiß ich nicht oder so bis Vietnam
und das denkt man natürlich den heutigen
Tagen auch ziemlich oft total ja und
dass ich dann aber denke dass sowas dass
solche Grundstimmungen das eigentlich
alles im Bach runter geht das ist das ja
schon oft gegeben hat und eben gerade im
Spätmittelalter war Messi janismus also
die die Hoffnung jetzt sozusagen der
Messias kommt und das tausendjährige
Reich Gottes bricht an oder die Welt
geht jetzt endgültig unter ganz ganz nah
beieinander und heute haben wir nicht
sehr viel Messianismus und so ja aber
doch doch finde es so sehr so Silicon
Valley vielleicht oder so doch der
Messias heißt heute ja Larry Page oder
oder Elon Musk oder Mark Zuckerberg okay
die machen sowas ja ja genau das das ist
der Messias und auf der anderen Seite
diese komplette Weltuntergangsstimmung
ja diese dieser ökosystemismus es ist eh
alles zu spät antinatalisten habe ich
gelernt du weißt was das ist natürlich
ich kannte das Wort nicht Leute die oder
junge Frauen vor allen Dingen die sagen
ich in diese Welt setzt sich doch keine
Kinder wir haben da schon mal drüber
gesprochen gesprochen also der
antinatalismus hatte in Deutschland
seinen ersten Boom in den 60ern und zwar
genau in der Zeit als ich geboren wurde
und ich bin Jahrgang 64 der
geburtenstärkste Jahrgang das
Interessante ist ja also ich alleine
nicht ja ich und einige Millionen mit
mir und so weiter ja also es gab nie so
viele Kinder in Deutschland wie 1964 und
das sind Kinder die sind quasi im
Zeichen der Kubakrise
geplant und angedacht worden und so
weiter ja geliefert worden genau also
genau in die Zeit wo man gesagt hat
jetzt kommt der Atomkrieg und jetzt geht
die Welt unter gibt's übrigens in
direkten Zusammenhang wir kriegen doch
jetzt wieder vergleichsweise viele
Kinder ne wirklich mit vorher also hier
fatalistischer die Welt Sicht umso mehr
Kinder kriegen die Menschen das ist
genau umgekehrt als man denken sollte
weil in Ländern in denen der Fatalismus
sehr berechtigt ist ja wenn man in den
Gegenden ins Lamms und sowas werden ja
sehr viele Kinder geboren ja also es ist
ja nicht dass die Menschen die für
persönlich die besten Zukunftsaussichten
haben die meisten Kinder kriegen da gibt
es überhaupt keinen Zusammenhang ich
glaube eher dass das so der
fatalistische Grundstimmung dazu führt
dass man stärker ins Private flüchtet
und versucht eine Harmonie in einem
kleinen Leben herzustellen wenn es schon
im großen nicht möglich ist und da
gehören für viele Menschen Kinder dazu
ich glaube die sind Zusammenhang gibt es
den würde ich dir sofort unterschreiben
mit Blick sozusagen auf unsere Welt mit
Blick auf die Menschen die ich zum Teil
in in Afrika aber auch in Indien in
indischen Slums und so weiter getroffen
habe für dich immer sagen da sind Kinder
einfach eine Überlebensgarantie
natürlich klar genau
für unseren Kulturkreis geht es also in
besonders fatalistischen
grundstimmungszeiten werden eher mehr
Kinder geboren und den optimistischen
Zeiten eher weniger man sieht sich
sozusagen zurück und im Schutz der
Dunkelheit entstehender neue Kinder baut
sich sein kleines Nest genau aber genau
dieser Punkt Richard und du erinnerst
dich ich hatte doch mit mit Carla Rochel
die bei der letzten Generation auch mit
dabei ist und sich gelegentlich auf
Straßen klebt und so weiter die geht mir
irgendwie nicht aus dem Kopf weil ich
mich hat das damals berührt du weißt ich
habe ja auch viel Prügel gekriegt weil
ich dann angeblich plötzlich Klima
Leugner waren so weiter haben wir schon
darüber gesprochen alles Quatsch mir
geht's um dieses Weltbild und auch das
haben wir schon öfter angesprochen ich
erlebe das wieder diese jungen Leute die
unglaublich pessimistisch in die Welt
schauen und mich macht das richtig
fertig weil ich immer denke was zum
Teufel machen wir falsch dass wir es
nicht schaffen dem Besten was wir haben
nämlich unseren Kindern an den
optimistischen Blick auf die Welt
mitzugeben wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
tatsächlich viel falsch gemacht haben
also wir sind ja jetzt wenn man da so
wie wir sagen kann im Prinzip die
Generation die am Ruder ist die sollen
den Fleischtöpfen ja genau unterscheiden
wir beide uns bei dem paar Jahren wir
uns trennen ja nicht und wir sind
irgendwie im Durchschnittsalter dessen
wo auch die Politiker sind
Regierungsverantwortung haben die die
CEOs der der großen Konzerne sind und so
weiter und es ist ja nun faktisch so
dass wir mit der Bedrohung des
Klimawandels und ich mag ja immer die
Reduktion auf das Thema Klimawandel
nicht ne weil für mich ist das
Aussterben der von harten Biodiversität
Umwelt Zerstörung für Plünderung des
Planeten Verseuchung der Meere und so
das gehört ja für mich alles mit dazu
und da muss man sagen dass diese
Generation nicht viel Gutes geleistet
hat das ist einfach wir haben die
Situation ja wir haben die Situation
unterm Strich verschlimmert und wir
haben keine Realpolitik gemacht die
angemessen wäre nun kann man sagen ist
das unser persönliches Versagen oder
geht's auch gar nicht anders ne kann man
beide Perspektiven drauf haben kann man
sagen wir haben uns doch bemüht wirklich
die jüngere Generation sagen also ein
richtig tolle Bemühungen war das nicht
ja und eine 4 - reicht nicht
ja ich ich ich finde aber das ist zu
einfach wir haben uns doch weiß Gott
angestrengt und und trotzdem ist daraus
jetzt so dieses dieses Gefühl geworden
dass auch das Grundgefühl meiner auch
deiner Jugend war das mal erzählt wie du
auch Bonner Hofgarten da warst du dabei
bei den großen Friedensdemonstrationen
und so weiter
da war ja das Gefühl kommen in diese
lieber rot als Tod und so weiter und
morgen geht die Welt sowieso auf in
Flammen und in einem riesigen nuklearen
Feuerball und dann ist das Thema
erledigt und dann gab es so ein paar
Jahrzehnte von den ich in der Rückschau
immer mehr denke mein Gott was waren das
für schöne goldene Jahre das sind die
Generation Golfjahr ne
wirklich ziemlich genau so Generation
Golf Golf Auto nicht Golf spielen nicht
wenn das ich meine das Auto also dieser
Bestseller von Florian Elis ja ja ja
Generation also ich habe ja mein Buch
über meine Kindheit geschrieben und das
von Florian Elis ist sozusagen also das
Gegenteil meines Buches ne also der ist
einfach so sechs sieben Jahre oder so
junge
und sein Lebensgefühl und das was ihn
glücklich gemacht hat und was ihm
bestimmt hat ist etwas ganz anderes
gewesen als meins das ist sozusagen die
cool Jugendzeit das waren die goldenen
Jahre der Bundesrepublik diese 80er
Jahre somit Frank Elstner als
Vertrauenslehrer der deutschen Spaß
Gesellschaft mit Helden wie Boris Becker
und Matthias Rust ja wo man delles
geguckt hat ja und der Aufstieg von
Dieter Bohlen begann also das ist
als Deutscher mit schlechten Fußball ja
zweimal im WM Finale stand 82 und 86
ja aber die diese 80er Jahre das war
irgendwo wahrscheinlich die Zeit wo
trotzdem wir haben ja beim letzten Mal
geredet über die nukleare Bedrohung na
das trotz all dem man so das Gefühl
hatte da war die Welt ziemlich gut und
dann kam die 90er Jahre da war auch noch
die nukleare Bedrohung weg und dann
hatte der Kapitalismus gewonnen und dann
waren die ganzen Bögen Kommunisten Weg
genau und dann hätte man gedacht das
geht jetzt ewig so weiter
diesen diesen Bestseller geschrieben
das Ende der Geschichte da steht jetzt
hier gerade 50 cm von mir entfernt im
Regal wirklich ja ja du weißt ja du hast
den ja mal getroffen weißt du erinnerst
du dich noch der hat der hat doch
ursprünglich war dann Fragezeichen
dahinter ne ja genau das war eine Frage
ursprünglich war das das auch eine er
ist ja viel zu intelligent und um es
eigentlich so plakativ zu sagen aber
aber der Anfang des Buches ist
programmatisch und da steht nach all den
tausendjährigen Auseinandersetzungen der
Menschheit und so weiter hat sich jetzt
endlich das System durchgesetzt was
quasi Frieden Freiheit und Wohlstand für
den ganzen Planeten bringt ne der
liberale Kapitalismus ist sozusagen die
bestmögliche Antwort und so glaube ich
wurde das auch von ganz vielen Menschen
tief empfunden dass man das Gefühl hat
zur richtigen Zeit am richtigen Ort und
jetzt wird es auch keine ganz
schreckliche Veränderung mehr geben ja
und die Frequenz der Mallorca Besucher
Namen ständig zu und so weiter er
Wohlstand haben zu der die Fuß Zeit wir
haben ja hier schon mal über mein idolf
gesprochen das sind die 80er 90er Jahre
der Vorarbeiter bei vor Ort kann sich
leisten ja mehrfach Urlaub zu machen
große Autos zu fahren und so weiter also
Ludwig Erhards Anspruch Wohlstand für
alle hat ja 1957 geschrieben und so
eingelöst wurde das so in den 80er 90er
Jahren total weißt du wohin ich gerade
lese Roger Willemsen den ich wahnsinnig
mochte den du wahrscheinlich auch öfter
mal getroffen hast der hat ein letztes
Buch geschrieben bzw in einem letzten
Buch gearbeitet was das mal gelesen wer
wir waren ja das ist kein Buch genau es
ist ein ist dass du Vortrag den in einer
Humboldt-Uni gehalten als es ist ein
grandios geschriebenes Stück grandios ja
das eben auch sagt wir waren die
Generation dies verurteilt hat das ist
schon der Trainer davon ja ja total
geht's auch ganz viele um um
Digitalisierung und so weiter und er
nennt dort und die die sozialen Medien
das selfie die autoerotische verviel
Besichtigung die filialexistenz des
eigenen ich großartig
aber es gibt es gibt doch weil du gerade
sagst modern er sagt da kann das Wort
modern auf der Begriff modern hatte noch
eine Bedeutung als Charlie Chaplin
seinen Film moderne
und zeitungsressort hatten plötzlich ein
Ressort mit dem Titel modernes Leben
modernes Leben hieß das in der Zeit und
der Redakteur der Chefredakteur der für
dieses Ressorts war es war 65 ja und
pass auf dich und er schreibt weiter und
die dümmste Musik hieß Modern Talking
und das würde ich so nie unterschreiben
ich war immer Fan von Modern Talking
okay das unterscheidet uns auf
Lebenszeit ja das war für mich die Erd
abgewandte Seite des Mondes also ich
wollte nie wie Dieter Bohlen sein und
und diese alte Indianerin wie hieß sie
Thomas Anders
vorsicht also Thomas Anders kenne ich
ein bisschen und das ist ein unfassbar
netter Mensch habe ich nicht den habe
ich gestellt ich habe eher sozusagen
Ästhetik und Musikalität angezeigt ja
und die Nora Kette und so weiter aber
man tut Thomas Anders sehr unrecht wenn
man ihn auf die Nora Kette reduziert
bestimmt und diese Musik damals das war
interessant mir hat Luis Rodriguez heißt
der glaube ich wenn ich mich richtig
erinnere das war der Produzent damals
von Modern Talking mit dem habe ich mal
ein bisschen so rum experimentiert Musik
gemacht das war so die Zeit in der ich
da auch unterwegs war und er hat mir mal
erzählt wie dieser Modern Talking
typisches Sound entstanden ist die
hatten da so ein komisches Rauschen auf
dem Band und haben das dann noch
rückwärts und vorwärts und so weiter und
immer wieder kopiert und laufen lassen
und irgendwann war dann da genau dieses
junge hat junger Soul dieser dieser neue
Sound da drin ich dachte das wäre so
eine geniale Einzelleistung von Dieter
Bohlen gewesen naja der Song ist sie
auch ein Geniestreich finde ich
unbedingt
streiten ja die geronimus ja okay gut
jetzt greifst du ganz ins unterste Regal
aber
Soul ist dass das war genial ich weiß
als ich dass das erste Mal gehört habe
habe ich gedacht
schadet es mir das nicht eingefallen ist
ach super ja okay ja ich hätte ich das
gerne auch Sinn gesehen kannst du ja
vielleicht auch mal irgendwann machen so
als Maß singer oder so ja aber du du
dehnst den Geniebegriff jetzt auch schon
ziemlich an alle Ränder aus ne na ja du
du ich ja ich habe heute einen haften
Tag die Einzel lass es doch mal nein
aber was ich meine ist und jetzt hast du
plötzlich wieder diesen diesen
kulturpässimismus und plötzlich hast du
die Leute die die wirklich der Meinung
sind morgen geht die Welt unter und es
ist alles vorbei und jetzt noch mal
jetzt noch mal sehr schön Roger
Willemsen der schreibt vor ungefähr 3,5
Millionen Jahren ist ein romyide in eine
Höhle gefallen vielleicht weiß ein
dickfälliger humorloser Materialist der
nie nach dem Sinn des Lebens fragte und
seit diesen Tagen ist der Mensch in der
Krise wenn man es genau bedenkt ist vom
Anfang aller Tage an alles immer
schlechter geworden Luft und Wasser
sowieso dann die Manieren die
politischen Persönlichkeiten der
Zusammenhalt das Herrentennis und das
Aroma der Tomaten und Roger schreibt
weiter man muss wirklich zitieren aus
dieser großartigen Rede er sagt ja der
Globus hat Homo sapiens ja und dessen
einzige sichere Zukunft ist die Krise
also wir haben immer Krise seit den
ersten Tagen ja Herren Tennis Tomaten
und wir geben dieser Krise immer neuen
Namen sagt der Klimaerwärmung
Übersäuerung der Meere Abschmelzen der
Gletscher Migration Burnout Dürre
Glaubenskriege Handelskriege der
Meeresspiegel die Wüsten die Austrocknen
die Ressourcen die Überbevölkerung
absterben multiresistente Keime wir
können es nicht mehr hören nicht wahr
und da ist noch Corona dazu gekommen
es gab nicht nur gelegentlich Krisen und
immer wieder sondern Krise war einfach
immer
und insofern ist doch die Frage wenn es
doch geschafft haben immer wieder aus
diesen krisenhaften Situationen
rauszukommen warum sind wir dann jetzt
plötzlich so pessimistisch hast du eine
Antwort darauf also erstmal kann man
Roger Willemsen unterstützen sagen es
gibt ein schönes Zitat von dem
Philosophen Udo Marquardt der gesagt hat
auch in der Krise ist immer mehr nicht
Krise als Krise ja sehr schön es ist
diese nicht Krise ist immer das was
keiner sieht wenn gerade Krise ist ja
gut sehr gut sehr gut gut aus der Kraft
der nicht Krise heraus kann man
natürlich auch viel Optimismus wieder
wieder machen außerdem muss man was
anderes sagen es ist das die
Zukunftserwartung die positive
Zukunftserwartung besteht ja nicht darin
dass plötzlich die Krisen aufhören
brecht hat gesagt die Welt ist nicht
schlecht die Welt ist voll ja und wenn
die Welt immer voller wird mit immer
mehr Menschen dann wird sie auch immer
komplizierter und wird auch immer Krisen
anfälliger ah durch die technische
Entwicklung B durch die die die große
Zahl ein Menschen die immer kompliziert
hatten politischen Konstellationen die
wachsenden Ansprüche in der Welt also
dann geht die Hoffnung ja nicht darauf
dass die Krisen aufhören sondern dass
wir resistenter mit Krisen umgehen
lernen das ist ja sozusagen die zentrale
Lektion fürs 21 Jahrhundert ja ist
richtig Richard und dann käme meine
Frage wie oft haben uns eigentlich schon
was düstere Prognosen angeht
katastrophal geirrt allein wenn du dir
den Bericht des Club of Rome anguckst
klar dass das Öl wäre längst zu Ende die
Gasvorräte Kupfer alles alles wir werden
im Grunde werden wir vollkommen erledigt
Tatsache ist wir haben erst dann ab dem
Zeitpunkt an dem eigentlich alles
angeblich zu Ende war angefangen richtig
wie entfesselt zu produzieren und ich
ich mal drei kurze Beispiele Richard ja
du erinnerst dich ist ganz berühmt der
der Kaiser will in der zweite besitzt in
eine Mercedes
Auto hat keine Zukunft ich setze auf das
Pferd die Zukunft gehört dem Pferd hatte
genau gott liebt Daimler 1901 pass auf
ich meine Daimler ja nicht irgendjemand
die weltweite Nachfrage nach
Kraftfahrzeugen wird eine Million nicht
überschreiten und jetzt pass auf und
zwar allein schon aus Mangel an
verfügbaren Chauffeuren ist das nicht
schön sehr schön ja er hatte er hätte
eigentlich noch übrigens dazu noch einen
anderen Grund angeben können warum das
Auto sich nicht so unendlich würde
durchsetzen können aus Mangel an Gummi
ja richtig nur dadurch dass die Belgier
im Kongo ja unendlich viel Kautschuk
unter barbarischen Umständen daraus
geschafft haben war überhaupt der
Siegeszug des Kraftfahrzeugs möglich mit
Holzrädern wäre da nicht viel drin
gewesen und jetzt denk mal an die Kobalt
Diskussion
Elektrofahrzeuge die gleichen
Diskussionen heute wieder im gleichen
Diskussion und es geht um die gleichen
Länder und es geht um die gleichen
Arbeitsbedingungen und es geht immer
wieder um eine Karre mit vier Rädern
dran und dann der will sein der der
Chef von der von der twenty Box ja das
auch schön ist schöner Satz 1946 der
Fernseher wird sich auf dem Markt nicht
durchsetzen denn die Menschen werden
sehr bald müde sein ich jeden Abend auf
eine Sperrholzkiste zu starren ist das
gut oder Thomas Watson kennst du IBM
über das watson-programm haben wir oft
gesprochen hier das Juristen die Arbeit
wegnimmt 43 1943 ich denke es gibt einen
Weltmarkt für maximal fünf Computer ja
das ist ganz bekannt ja und es ist gab
ganz häufig Prognosen ich glaube in den
80er Jahren ganz Anfang der 80er Jahre
gab es noch irgend so ein IT Ikone die
gesagt hat
kein Mensch braucht ein PC ja ja ja also
solche Fehlprognosen gibt es in Massen
kennen Olsen das ist kein Olsen es gibt
keinen Grund warum jeder ein Computer zu
Hause haben sollte 77 ja ja ja kann man
auch sagen gibt's ja vielleicht auch
nicht
besteht darin dass alle anderen auch ein
Computer zu Hause haben muss und dass
man irgendwann nicht mehr in dieser Welt
lebt wenn man keinen hat er ist richtig
aber aus der Welt von 77 gab es auch
keinen Grund also der Computer war wie
fast jeder techn Fortschritt dieser Art
zunächst eine Antwort auf eine nicht
gestellte Frage also es war nicht so
dass vor eine Milliarde Menschen
unbedingt Computer haben wollte und
deswegen wurde erfunden sondern der
Bedarf wurde ja überhaupt erst geweckt
und durch den richtig veränderten Bedarf
und die Tatsache dass viele den hatten
änderte sich die gesamte Lebenswelt auch
die Arbeitswelt und so weiter und wenn
du heute mit dem Computer nicht umgehst
dann hast du ein riesiges Problem und
dadurch entsteht dann natürlich am Ende
der Druck das quasi alle dabei sind der
Punkt ist Richard weißt du noch mal die
antinatalisten ja dieser Satz in diese
Welt setzt sich doch keine Kinder und
das ist ein vorherrschendes Gefühl im
Moment bei vielen jungen Leuten ja meine
musst du mal überlegen du um um das
Leben den Planeten zu schützen
verzichtest du darauf selber leben in
die Welt zu setzen ist doch völlig
paradox wieso naja also jeder Mensch der
auf diesem Planeten lebt hat hinterlässt
einen ökologischen Fußabdruck und der
ist in unseren Ländern sehr groß ja da
kann man viel so argumentieren die auch
und wenn man dann sagt ich adoptiere
lieber Kinder aus der Dritten Welt und
bekomme selber keine und was weiß ich
was oder so oder helfe da oder so also
ich sag nicht dass es meine
Argumentation ist aber so unschlüssig
ist das nicht ja genauso wird ja
argumentiert ne also wenn du richtig CO2
sparen willst dann kriegst du keine
Kinder elf Tonnen jährlich imitiert der
Durchschnittsdeutsche und deswegen sagt
sagen viele Bewegungen es gibt diese
birth Strike Bewegung ja die sagen
Kinderlosigkeit das hat den größten
Einfluss im positiven Sinne auf die
Klimakrise und interessant ist
statistisches Bundesamtes nicht
irgendjemand die sagen dass der Anteil
Heranwachsender ist auf einem absoluten
Tiefstand Jugendliche im Alter von 15
bis 24 stellen nur noch Richard Frage
wie viel Prozent der Gesamtbevölkerung
in Deutschland in Deutschland die 15 bis
24-Jährigen lieber die wir gerade reden
also sie müssten ja sie müssten ja ne so
ungefähr
von Natur aus zwölf Prozent glaube ich
da mehr 80 Millionen sind und das sind
zehn Prozent also
müssten 12 Prozent darstellen
wahrscheinlich sind es nur sechs oder
sieben es sind zehn zehn ja 83 waren es
noch fast 17 Prozent könnte man
aufrunden und sagen fast doppelt so
viele ja das war die die Zeit unserer
Jugend und das merkt man doch ja wir
waren viele du warst ja schon ein paar
weniger du bist ja schon eine Pillen
geknickt nur das ist in Südtirol
wahrscheinlich verboten war da gab es
keine Schwangerschaftsverhütung als du
geboren wurde das war Teufels Zeug und
ich weiß wurde viel darüber diskutiert
aber jetzt daraus zu machen dass es mit
meiner Ankunft ist auch eine sehr starke
these finde ich nein das wollte ich
nicht genauso sein es ist nicht der
antimissias du gerade angedeutet aber ja
dieser dieser Fatalismus Richard ja
inshallah ja es ist es ist einfach
sozusagen es ist wie es ist ja könnte
man auch sagen JA aber das ist kein
vorteilismus dass der kölsche Taoismus
das sind ganz große unter der Kölner ist
kein Fatalist sondern ist Tau ist die
Dinge wie sie sind ja er stellt Dinge
die man nicht ändern kann ich in Frage
ja ja genau ich würde sagen also die die
kölsche Philosophie das Kölsche
Grundgesetz ist voller tauistischer
Weisheiten großartig ja dass du du hast
junger mau ist auf dem Weg nach Köln der
Maro ist bin ich nie gewesen von Mao ist
zum Tao ist geworden einer schöne
Geschichte aber Maro war bei uns zu
Hause kam schlecht weggemacht immer
zurecht auch ja voll zu Recht
aber also Tao ist ja genau das ist schön
aber das ist doch eine gute Haltung die
die die die rheinische Haltung zum Leben
ist doch eine gute Haltung weil sie im
Kern ja eine positive Haltung ist also
der der Fatalismus der Unterschied ist
der Fatalismus entsteht ja aus einer
Verzweiflung ja ich muss mich in etwas
fügen ob ich will oder nicht das
mächtiger größer ist als ich also in
Gottes Willen oder in ein programmierten
Weltlauf wie die Stoiker sagten alle
2000 Jahre brennt die Erde ab ja ob man
kann man nichts dran ändern egal was man
für Politik macht oder was man macht die
muss ich verändern oder die
evolutionären Fatalisten die sagen ne
der Mensch ist Tierart die sich am
meisten vermehrt das wird immer mehr und
mehr mehr geben dann gibt es immer
weniger Ressourcen gibt es immer mehr
Kriege und am Ende geht alles kaputt das
sind das sind ja sozusagen man ist einer
höheren Gewalt ausgeliefert und
eigentlich ist man deswegen verzweifelt
und der Kölner ist eben nicht
verzweifelt
sondern sagt er ist ja kein Grund zum
Verzweifeln ja
zum nächsten Köln aber das ist gerade
interessanter Punkt ich habe wenn man
sagt es ist eh wie es ist
es kommt wie es kommt auch in einem
Negativ ich kann ja eh nichts machen was
Gottes ist tot
für diese diese dieses ausgeliefert sein
ja ich sozusagen der kleine Arme Tor ja
und und über mir mächtige
Gewalten gegen die ich nichts ausrichten
kann was ja interessant ist weil es ja
zur Frage führt
jemand wie harari zum Beispiel
beschäftigt sich ja viel damit der sagt
es gibt ja gar keinen freien Willen und
insofern ist alles das ist dann so der
terministisch es ist alles vorher
bestimmt ich habe das ja auch
nachgeguckt bei hararen also mich hat
das ja immer gestört also das was er
über Willensfreiheit erzählt dass das
ist würde warum soll ich seine starke
Seite ja das muss man ganz klar sagen er
hat ja echt das ist jetzt du bist kurz
vor vor Gotteslästerung weißt du ne nein
nein nein nein also er ist ein
glänzender Militärhistoriker ja und und
alles was er sozusagen seine neue
Perspektive dir auf die die Geschichte
des Menschen geworfen hat ist gerade in
den Sachen wenn er über 90 jahrhundert
schreibt was 18 Jahrhundert wie
Aufklärung und so sehr durch seine
militärgeschichtliche Expertise die hat
er neue reingebracht und das ist auch
durchaus interessant
aber was die Sache mit dem freien will
da hat er was aufgeschnappt was er nicht
richtig verstanden hat entschuldigung
wenn ich das so klar sage sieht jetzt so
aus wie Stuten bis unter Bestseller
Autoren nein nicht so gemeint nein aber
es muss man es muss man wirklich sagen
also er sagt Menschen haben keinen
freien Willen weil sie in soziale
Kontexte eingebunden sind ja das ist
doch sofort hergestellt also wer welcher
Philosoph hat sich jemals den freien
Willen so vorgestellt dass unser Wille
von nichts anderem abhängig ist als von
irgendeiner autonom getroffenen inneren
Entscheidung also das wird man nicht
finden also das diese Vorstellung ich
kann vollkommen tun und lassen was ich
will ungeachtet meiner Biografie meiner
Sozialisation dessen was ich gestern
erlebt habe was ich in meiner Kindheit
erlebte das ist ja Unsinn das bestreitet
er eben er sagt Menschen haben einen
Willen aber dieser Wille ist nicht
wirklich frei ja aber er begründet ist
er begründet dass Gott sei Dank muss man
sagen mit dieser sozialen kulturellen
Eingebundenheit es gibt ja eine viel
härtere Variante die viel härter
Variante sind ja diejenigen Leute die
sagen sah sie mit neurobiologischen
Argumenten sagen es gibt keine
Willensfreiheit da sind es die
hardcore-variante und das harari macht
ist die soft-variante und damit tritt er
eine Tür ein die sperrangel weit offen
steht aber der Gedanke Richert er sagt
Menschen haben ihre Gene sie haben ihr
Geschlecht sie haben ihre Eltern sie
haben ihre Nachbarn sie haben ihre
Kultur all das hast du einfach kriegst
du frei Haus geliefert wählst du nicht
suchst du dir nicht aus also schon mal
sozusagen Abwesenheit von freiem Willen
und dann pass auf und dann sagt er
versucht doch mal den nächsten Gedanken
den du denkst bewusst zu verfolgen wo
kam der her hast du dich frei
entschieden genau das zu denken ja was
hast du im Anschluss gedacht und so
weiter hätte hätte warum jetzt wird es
Leuchte doch rein ja weil jetzt werden
lauter Sachen lauter Sachen
zusammengeschmissen wenn ich also jetzt
Bratpfanne sage ja wir haben ja mal Toni
groß und die Bratpfanne Podcast
besprochen so habe ich das jetzt gerade
eben sozusagen zwanghaft gemacht weil
der Algorithmus meines Gehirns mir in
dem Moment wo ich von dir höre frei und
Handlung und sprechen das diktiert hat
oder habe ich mir das ausgesucht und
hätte auch Spiegelei statt Bratpfanne
sagen können so und das ist nicht die
terminiert durch meine Kindheit mein
kulturelles Umfeld um was weiß ich was
alles da müsste man ein viel
umfassenderen Beweis antreten das ist
ein Algorithmus meines Denkens gibt aus
dem ich in keiner Form irgendwo
rauskomme und der vollkommen materiell
biochemisch determiniert ist nicht dass
er in dem Moment etwas biochemisches in
meinem Kopf stattfindet das ist
geschenkt sondern dass diese Biochemie
im Grunde genommen vorgibt was ich denke
ja und das ist ja das ist ja die
Position auch von Nora Biologen ne der
hat rot z.B genau und jetzt als erstes
würde ich mal wissen bevor ich mir Mühe
gebe das zu widerlegen wie plausibel
findest du das denn das ist kein freien
Willen gibt meinst du jetzt naja ja das
ist im neurobiologischen Sinne keinen
freien Willen gibt ich ich bin ja nicht
so schlau wie jemand wie Gerd rot zum
Beispiel ja der ist ein Kollege von dir
Philosoph emeritierter Neurobiologe der
geht genauso wie Harare und jetzt steht
schon zwei zu eins gegen dich Richard
davon aus dass der freie Wille eine
Illusion ist ich weiß er sagt nämlich
das interessant dass wir unser
Bewusstsein quasi regelmäßig ausschalten
und zwar aus dem simplen Grund weil
unser Gehirn viel zu viel Energie
braucht ja das ist aber nicht sein
Hauptargument nur mal am Ende gesagt ja
was ist ein Argument und er sagt schon
im Ruhezustand verbraucht das Gehirn
ungefähr 20% unserer Energie ja aber da
spricht nicht gegen freien Willen das
kann hochgehen auf der pass auf dass die
These ist doch interessant kann
hochgehen auf bis zu 60 70% wer wer
nachdenkt wer geistig arbeitet verbrannt
unfassbar viel Energie so schön und das
bedeutet in der allermeisten Zeit sind
sie sozusagen auf Autopilot unterwegs
wenn wir durch den Alltag laufen wenn
wir Wasser trinken ja also unser
Bewusstsein hätte es überhaupt nicht für
nötig jetzt irgendwie einen größeren
Prozess im Kopf auszulösen wenn man
Durst hat
ist es läuft alles unterbewusstes wir
denken gar nicht wirklich drüber nach so
würde ich auch sofort unterschreiben
genau und der Punkt an dem der Schalter
im Kopf quasi umgelegt wird ja ist dann
wenn zwei Fragen auftauchen ist das neu
und ist das wichtig wenn das nicht
passiert dann interessiert das keine Sau
und er sagt diesen bewusst
Entscheidungen geht aber trotzdem immer
ein gehirnvorgang voraus der CA an der
halbe Sekunde vorher stattfindet also
das das schmeißt auch ganz viel
verschiedenes durcheinander ich zitiere
nur Gerhard rot genau ist was Gerhard
zitiert sind Experimente ne Benjamin
Liebert ist ein Hirnforscher gewesen der
Experimente gemacht hat und in diesen
Experimenten nachgewiesen hat dass ich
eine bestimmte Armbewegung die ich
machen soll ausführe bevor mein Gehirn
begriffen hat dass der Abend den Befehl
gekriegt hat sie auszuführen
unterbewusst so das sind die Liebe
Experimente das heißt also das nennt der
bereitschaftspotenzial nennt die Zeit
zwischen a und das heißt also der Körper
reagiert schneller handelt schneller als
unser Gehirn kapiert hat dass es den
Befehl dazu gegeben hat das ist die
Pointe der libert Experimente ich habe
mir Gerhard Roth zweimal lange darüber
diskutiert einmal für den Spiegel vor 15
Jahren und einmal an der Uni in Lüneburg
ich weiß nicht ob das damals gefilmt
wurde da haben wir auch anderthalb
Stunden über Willensfreiheit diskutiert
so um das interessante damit ist was ist
denn eigentlich überhaupt ein Wille da
tut sich Herr Roth ähnlich wie sein
Kollege Wolf singer mit dem man dann
gemeinsam damals
Vorstoß gemacht hat und gesagt hat es
gibt keine Willensfreiheit wir sollten
neu über das Strafrecht nachdenken in
relativ trüben Gewässer die Frage ist
nämlich wenn ich ein Experiment mache wo
ich auf ein bestimmtes Signal hin mein
Arm bewegen soll oder genauer mein
Handgelenk ist das dasselbe wie dem
Beschluss zu fassen Mathe zu studieren
beides würden wir sagen ist eine
Willensentscheidung ne das eine ist die
Willensentscheidung ich klappe jetzt
meinen Handgelenk runter und das zweite
ist die willensentsch ich habe mich nach
langem Hin und Her entschieden doch
nicht
Betriebswirtschaft zu studieren sondern
Mathe so beides würden wir mit dem
Begriff des Willens zusammenbringen und
ich würde sagen die beiden Sachen haben
erstmal so gut wie überhaupt nichts
zueinander zu tun weil das eine ist eine
körperliche Reflex und das zweite ist
ein unglaublich komplizierter
Entscheidungsprozess in dem ganz ganz
ganz viele verschiedene Dinge
eingeflossen sind also bei mir wenn du
mich vor die Frage stellst würde ich
Mathe studieren wäre auch ein ganz
schneller körperlicher Reflex ein
gewisses Unwohlsein ein Schwindel der in
die aufstößt genau aber bei den Leuten
die sich dafür entscheiden ist es
vermutlich anders das heißt also der
Begriff ist Willes ja der umfasst ganz
lange bewusste reflektierte
Entscheidungen der umfasst triebhaft ist
ne also du du siehst jemand findest den
attraktiv hast du dir nicht ausgesucht
ist einfach so oder du siehst was und
findest alles sieht lecker aus als würde
ich gerne essen auf der Ebene gibt es
keine Willensfreiheit
auf der Ebene ob du das jetzt isst oder
ob du denjenigen anquatscht oder so da
kommt doch schon wieder viel viel mehr
ins Spiel und wir nennen das alles Wille
wir nennen sozusagen den reinen
reflexmechanismus nennen wir Wille und
es gibt ja viele Stufen wo Benjamin
Liebe Bett die interessante Formulierung
benutzt hat dass er gesagt hat Menschen
haben keinen freien Willen aber sie
haben einen freien Unwille okay der
freie Unwille der darin besteht trotz
eines willenbeschlusses es nicht zu tun
das heißt also dieser Benjamin Liebe der
immer als Quelle dafür da steht dass der
Mensch keinen freien Willen hat war
gerade im Gegenteil davon überzeugt dass
wir einen haben interessant ja und die
die da drauf gesattelt haben und gesagt
das ist jetzt mal der Beweis und rot
geht's um folgendes rot möchte sagen als
Naturwissenschaftler
alles das was sich da oben in unserem
Gehirn abspielt steht in einem
Kausalverhältnis zueinander Ursache und
Wirkung und es kann doch nicht sein dass
da plötzlich etwas ist was nicht aus
Ursache und Wirkung besteht sondern wo
sozusagen das freie ich der freie Wille
ins Spiel kommt das ist eigentlich seine
hauptargumentation und auch da meine ich
liegt der falsch und jetzt kommt mein
naturwissenschaftliches Gegenargument es
ist möglich in den Naturwissenschaften
das bestimmte Elemente sich so
miteinander verbinden dass eine neue
Qualität entsteht zum Beispiel Leben
Leben besteht aus lauter Baustein die
ihrerseits nicht leben Moleküle Proteine
und so weiter ja aber eine bestimmte
Kombination aus ihnen schafft neue
Eigenschaften der Fachbegriff dafür ist
immer ergänzt also die Idee dass
sozusagen eins und eins nicht zwei
sondern drei ist ja es kommt etwas hinzu
sozusagen die Summe ist mehr als die
Teile der enthält Eigenschaften die die
Teile nicht haben richtig Bewusstsein
ist das gleiche Gerhard Roth würde nicht
bestreiten dass es Bewusstsein gibt aber
es ist bis heute zwar erklärlich welche
Bestandteile im Gehirn zu Bewusstsein
führen dass wir dafür Neuronen haben und
den dritten und Axone und Synapsen und
was ich alles im Gehirn abspielt
trotzdem ist damit die Qualität von
Bewusstsein nicht erklärt das ist ein
uraltes Problem zwischen
Naturwissenschaftlern die das Gehirn
untersuchen und Philosophen
das heißt auch hier wieder ein imagenz
Phänomen wenn aber Bewusstsein an dem
ergänzphänomen ist warum soll nicht der
freie Wille als Teil des Bewusstsein
auch ein ergänzphänomen sein und die
Tatsache dass ich sozusagen mein
Handgelenk eher bewege als dass ich
kapiere dass ich mir den Befehl selbst
gegeben habe ihn zu bewegen trifft eben
nur auf relativ simplen Ebenen zu ja und
würde ehrlich gesagt ja auch das
bestätigen was er sagt also wenn wenn
das so viel Energie verbraucht dann ist
es ja naheliegend dass das solche
einfachen dubiosen Tätigkeiten einfach
das Unterbewusstsein ausführt dafür
schaltest du die große Maschine erst gar
nicht an die Automatismus Theorie ist
völlig das ist auch so wenn du mal
aufschreiben solltest am Abend was du
alles gemacht hast an dem Tag würde dir
erheblicher Teil der Dinge nicht mehr
einfallen
oder ein schönes Beispiel ist wenn ich
früher in Köln ausgegangen bin und bin
dann abends so drei Kilometer von meinem
Lieblingsladen nach Hause gegangen ne
und ich warte unglaublich viel getrunken
dann liege ich am nächsten Morgen im
Bett und ich kann mich noch daran
erinnern dass ich da in diesem Laden war
aber ich kann mich an nichts erinnern
was ich auf diesem Heimweg abgespielt
hat
also ich frage mich wir haben meine
Schritte den Weg zur Wohnung in dem
Zustand überhaupt gefunden sie finden
aber das ist das Gedächtnis des Körpers
es gibt so viele Dinge die wir
automatisiert machen ist richtig ja ein
guter Autofahrer unterscheidet sich von
einem lausigen Autofahrer wie mich
dadurch dass er ganz vieles
automatisiert aus dem FF beherrscht dass
er gerade nicht nachdenkt in bestimmten
Verkehrssituationen genau
runter zu laufen wenn du wenn du
anfängst darüber nachzudenken was die
nächste Stufe ist dann stolperst du
genau in dem Moment stolperto ja oder
beim Reden darüber nachdenken was deine
Zuge gerade macht und bringt dich dazu
irgendwann kein Wort mehr artikulieren
kannst also das stimmt völlig mit der
automatisiertheit aber es ist überhaupt
kein Widerspruch zu dem freien Willen
also freier will als immer ganz Phänomen
ja das Ding ist ja Richard weil du
Fundus ist dass das so nebenbei erwähnt
wie wir müssen ja als Gesellschaft daran
glauben dass es sowas wie ein freien
Willen gibt Strafrecht sagtest du gerade
ich meine wenn wenn jemand müssen
umbringt und du könntest vor Gericht
argumentieren und sagen naja das war ja
gar nicht sein frei Wille das wollte der
ja gar nicht sondern er wurde durch eine
seltsame
synapsenkombinationen dazu gezwungen ja
der arme Mann er ist eigentlich er ist
eigentlich das Opfer dann wird's halt
schwierig ne ja das war ja der
ursprüngliche Vorstoß von Rot und singer
ne dass sie gesagt haben lass uns mal
neu über Strafrecht reden das ist nicht
mehr rot Meinung soweit ich weiß heute
was war der Gedanke dahinter also
wahrscheinlich allein aus aus einem
gewissen Pragmatismus heraus weil die
auch Menschen die Gerhardt die davon
überzeugt sind dass es keinen freien
Willen gibt müssen sich in jeder
Lebenslage in der Sie sich befinden so
handeln als ob es ihn gebe ja das meine
ich ich kann mich doch dann wenn mich
jemand geärger durch mich mit jemand
streite ja und jemand beleidigt mich
dann wüsste ich ja dann an
rotsperspektive sondern
für komische Algorithmen im Kopf so ich
müsste für alles Verständnis haben es
gibt keine Schuld es gibt kein Gut und
Böse mehr es gibt nur noch Maschinen
Tomaten die miteinander agieren und ich
finde das stärkste Argument aber das ist
jetzt mehr aphoristisch das stärkste
Argument gegen die These dass es keinen
freien Willen gibt besteht darin dass
diejenigen die daran glauben Null
Konsequenzen daraus ziehen und dann
könnte ich sagen okay wenn sie Recht
hätten was ich aus den gerade genannten
Gründen nicht glaube aber wenn sie Recht
hätten dann leben wir haben wir keinen
freien Willen aber wir haben acht
Milliarden Menschen nur wie viel wir
bald sind haben die feste
Illusion dass sie einen freien Willen
haben und diese Illusion verbindet sie
alle miteinander und sie alle leben in
diesem gleichen illusionären Film und
wenn das dann tatsächlich so ist dann
spielt die Frage vielleicht gar keine
Rolle mehr dann ist die
Illusion korrigiert quasi in unserem
täglichen Leben die Realität und ich
glaube das ist so bei Leuten wie rot die
einfach ganz normal weiterleben mit
einer Erkenntnis die einem von heute auf
morgen ein völlig anderes Leben wird man
könnte seine Kinder nicht mehr
anschreiben man hätte keinen Grund mehr
dafür man kann es vielleicht auch nicht
mal mehr Sinn sie ernsthaft zu
korrigieren ich kann niemanden mehr böse
sein ja ist schon klar weil du immer
sagen musst na gut das will der ja gar
nicht aber seine Synapse gibt ihm das
gerade vor da ist halt so gepolt und ich
meine das Strafrecht trägt dem aber das
wäre jetzt noch mal ein ein halbherziger
Versuch eines gegenarguments der der
Mord aus Affekt zum Beispiel ne das
trägt er mir ein gewisser Weise Rechnung
also sozusagen da habe ich jemanden
umgebracht weil ich die Situation der
emotionale Ausnahmezustand ich wollte
das gar nicht aber mein anderes ich war
einfach stärker dieses ich glaube beim
Auto und ich wollte das vielleicht in
diesem Moment ja aber ich meine Wille
war nicht das Ergebnis einer längeren
Planung also Mord ist ja sozusagen
bewusst geplante Tötung und bei Mord im
Affekt geht es ja darum dass ich etwas
getan habe was ich sozusagen in dieser
Sekunde wollte sonst hätte ich es ja
nicht getan ja das ist dann der
Unterschied zwischen Mord und Totschlag
ne ja aber was ich nicht was ich nicht
überlebt habe was ich genau was ich
nicht in Ruhe überlegt habe ja oder
darauf hingearbeitet habe oder da ist
keine Hinterlist bei und so weiter aber
das bestätigt die Willensfreiheit denn
der Mord im Effekt ist ja nur deswegen
weniger schrecklich ja juristisch
gesehen als der Mord juristischer ja ja
weil er die Ausnahme von der Regel
darstellt normalerweise denkt man wenn
man jemanden umbringt dann bringt jemand
den ja um weil er das wirklich sich gut
überlegt hat und dieses gut überlegt
kann er ja nur haben wenn dann freien
Willen hat richtig was heißt also wir
machen milder eine Umstände geltend für
Situationen in denen der freie Wille
getrübt ist aber das Strafrecht
unterstellt den freien Willen und damit
die Schuld Mündigkeit ich meine
interessantes Jahr wenn wir darüber
reden dass wir in einer Zeit leben in
der sozusagen der die die die
Biotechnologie ja und der Mensch das
verschmilzt langsam miteinander wir
haben ja schon mal sehr ausführlich über
sogenannte künstliche Intelligenz
gesprochen ja
GPT und ähnliches und wir haben ja
damals auch festgehalten Intelligenz ist
eigentlich ja was anderes Intelligenz
ist ja wirklich begreifen was die
Maschine macht ist ja aus unfassbar
vielen Informationen Maschinen learning
ja ist ja sozusagen daraus ein Muster zu
stricken und wenn eine bestimmte
Kombination aus Buchstaben sozusagen in
die Maschine reingeht dann sagt die
Maschine okay dann muss jetzt mit einer
sehr großen Wahrscheinlichkeit diese
andere Buchstabenkombination aus mir
wieder herauskommen aber ist ja was
anderes als Intelligenz Intelligenz
bedeutet ja sehr sehr sehr viel mehr
bedeutet ja begreifen aber was wenn du
irgendwann in der Lage bist so ein
menschliches Gehirn wirklich nicht nur
vielleicht
in die Cloud hochzuladen sondern
wirklich zu Hecken einzugreifen und und
was würden starten damit anfangen würden
starten wenn Sie in der Lage wären
menschliche Intelligenz ja zu verstehen
wie das funktioniert
das Ganze schwingen die biochemischen
Vorgänge da einzugreifen was würden sie
dann damit tun würden sie tendenziell
gute Menschen empathische Menschen
soziale Menschen daraus machen oder
würden Sie je nachdem in welchem Teil
der Welt man zu Hause ist daraus
skrupellose Krieger machen die gar kein
Problem haben auf andere zuzugehen und
sie einfach umzubringen ich glaube auf
in erster Linie volksarme Menschen zum
Beispiel das hätten wahrscheinlich viele
verschiedene Regierungen gemeinsam also
brave Untertan hervorbringen richtig ja
die gute Nachricht ist wir werden das
beide nicht mehr erleben also die
Komplexität des menschlichen Gehirns na
das komplizierte System im Universum
das werden wir so schnell nicht hacken
können das werden wir auch so schnell
nicht nachbauen können dieses Ziel gibt
es ja dass man denkt dass man irgendwie
auf künstliche Art und Weise
menschliches Gehirn bauen kann also
Modell was im Grunde genommen genauso
funktioniert das Problem ist unser
menschliches Gehirn ist sehr sehr stark
abhängig von unserer Physiologie also es
ist Gehirn eines eines Tieres also von
unserem Körper also es ist ja nicht nur
dass unser Gehirn denkt es gibt ja auch
sowas wie ein Gedächtnis des Körpers
es gibt eine unmittelbare Zusammenspiel
unserer körperlichen Bedürfnisse und
unserer geistigen Gelüste
also weil der Körper eben diese Hunger
hat gibt es also das Bedürfnissen nach
Nahrungsaufnahme hat gibt es den
entsprechenden Schalter im Gehirn dann
der uns dann sagt hier und weiter wir
sind hungrig und so das spielt ja alles
zusammen unsere ganze Bedürfnisstruktur
auch unsere willensstruktur was wir
wollen was wir begehren ja wann wir uns
blöd fühlen wann wir uns stark fühlen
wann wir uns schwach fühlen das ist ja
alles ohne eine Physiologie nicht
vorstellbar also ohne einen Körper
deswegen ist das was wir da irgendwo
nachbauen müsste eigentlich an einen
Physiologie angeschlossen sein sonst
wird das nichts mit menschlichen gern
sonst wird das irgendwas anderes und das
alles hat einen Komplex Kreis Ziele
Komplexitätsgrad und Kompliziertheit
gerade also beides ne kompliziert ist
wenn man die Teile auch noch auseinander
sortieren kann komplex ist wenn das
ganze zu etwas wird wo man die Teile
nicht mehr auseinanderhalten kann
und das ist so enorm dass das so schnell
nicht passieren wird weil das würde
jetzt abschließend Richard ja bedeuten
also wir hatten jetzt fest es gibt aus
deiner Sicht den freien Willen und das
würde ja bedeuten dass wir deshalb auch
die Freiheit besitzen uns entweder einen
pessimistischen oder einen
optimistischen Blick auf die Welt zu
leisten und es würde ja auch bedeuten
wenn wir wenn wir
jetzt vor der Situation stehen vor der
wir gerade stehen ja irgendwas ist immer
und alles scheiße Elli dann wäre doch
eigentlich jetzt unsere Aufgabe uns
darum zu kümmern und zu sagen pass auf
wir brauchen trotzdem einen
optimistischen Blick in die Zukunft im
Sinne von wir haben gigantische
Herausforderungen das bestreite doch
keiner und wir haben all die Themen über
die wir sprechen aber wir müssen das
optimistisch annehmen und gestalten also
ich habe mit dem freien will nicht sagen
wollen ja dass dieser Wille komplett
isoliert von allem ist und die Frage ob
wir optim pessimistisch es ist erstmal
keine Willensentscheidung sondern in
erster Linie eine Frage unserer
Neurotransmitter
das heißt also wer von Serotonin
überflutet wird ja der ist hat eine
gelassenere Grundstimmung zur Welt als
jemand der sie rot von ihnen Mangel hat
auch wir sind ja mich ja gerade
beschrieben habe unser Gehirn von
unserer Physiologie abhängig die Sache
ist dann nur wie kann unser Geist damit
umgehen dass wir zu wenig Serotonin
haben oder wie wie wie der eigenen
Problematik Bewusstsein lernen damit
umzugehen sie anders zu deuten da haben
wir diese Freiheit wir haben nicht die
Freiheit der Empfindung was wir
empfinden ist nicht frei aber wie wir
mit den Empfindungen umgehen da kommt
ein gewisses Quantum an Freiheit mit ins
Spiel
und es ist natürlich völlig klar ich
meine wenn wir jetzt Fatalisten würden
oder wenn wir pessimistisch sind dann
haben wir verloren
wie Goethe gesagt hat nein nur die Sache
ist verloren die man aufgibt ja
umgekehrt bedeutet das alles was man
aufgeht ist auch verloren
und wenn es genug Leute gibt die
aufgeben dann ist die Sache verloren
ungeachtet dessen dass sie vielleicht
rettbar oder so gewesen sind und ich
habe mit Jane Modell mal gefragt warum
sie so optimistisch ist die berühmte
affenforscherin ja die berühmte
primatenvorschriften und sie hat mir
eine spannende Antwort gegeben sie hat
gesagt sie wäre nicht optimistisch sie
hätte Hoffnung ist richtig deswegen
großer Unterschied also Optimismus war
für sie eher so weiß ich habe das alles
rational durchdacht und bin zum guten
Ergebnis gekommen und so ist das nicht
sondern sie sagt ich habe das sinngemäß
rational als ich dachte und ich komm zu
mir ziemlich schrecklichen Ergebnis ja
aber ich gebe die Hoffnung nicht auf
und wenn wir uns darauf einigen können
sind wir auf dem besseren Weg als wenn
wir hoffnungslos drangehen ja weil wenn
wir die Hoffnung haben dass es besser
wird dann sind wir vielleicht auch
wieder bereit Kindern die Welt zu setzen
eine Familie zu gründen und eben nicht
so fatalistisch zu sein ja also
Fatalismus ist keine Lösung Matthias
robinski kennst du auch Kollege Autor
von der Süddeutschen
des sagt von sich ich bin so ein
Teilzeit Fatalist das gefällt mir das
finde ich gut das finde ich auch gut
schön wenn ich drogenski richtig
verstehe hatte er damit sagen wollen man
muss nicht ständig mit allem kämpfen man
muss sich nicht ständig optimieren
wollen auch nicht verkämpfen ne ja nicht
nicht genau nicht mit der Nase in jedem
quatschen
ja sondern auch mal gelassen sein von
Wittgenstein gibt es den den Satz mein
Leben besteht daraus dass ich mich mit
manchen begnüge
und das ist gelebter Teilzeit Fatalismus
gegen den ist überhaupt nichts zu sagen
und dann der Teilzeit Fatalist der kann
auch gut als kölscher Tau ist durch
gerade sagen genau
das war spannend hat Spaß gemacht danke
sehr gut tschüss
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pots
bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF